but Dr Jane what's the most important
message that you want to share with
people about our world what do you think
the most important thing is I think the
most important thing is to remember that
every day we live on this planet
we make an impact and we get to choose
what sort of impact we make but in order
to be able to choose we have to
alleviate poverty because if you're
really poor you can't choose as we all
can you know don't buy that because it
was bad for the environment or cruel to
animals or bad cheap because of unfair
Wages that's really important isn't it
yes everything is connected yeah well
let's do a quick commercial break
everybody
um you all be sure to watch Jane you can
find it on Apple TV Plus
[Music]
[Applause]